tic la politique toujours et à un mois
du scrutin des régionales coûte
projecteurs ce soir sur le modem
où en est le parti de françois bayrou
malmené dans les sondages certains le
disent de plus en plus isolé cependant
le leader du parti centriste lui refuse
ce constat alors at il choisi de faire
le dos rond le temps de ce scrutin en
attendant celui qui le motive avant tout
la présidentielle éléments de réponse
avec valérie astruc josé boulesteix qui
l'ont rencontré regardez pas de
distribution de tracts pas de meeting
national et régional françois bayrou
tente de sauver les meubles et faire
bonne figure non ça me fait plaisir
ce qui lui fait moins plaisir ce sont
les défections qui en ce moment sans
chaînes
en ile-de-france un sénateur modem vient
de rallier la liste ump en poitou
charentes à 5 modem ont rejoint ségolène
royal leur chef de file a été suspendu
par françois bayrou et pourtant il vient
de recevoir un colis remplis de livres
orange à distribuer je me dis que ça
prouve que c'est un parti qui est pas
gérer qu'il faut organiser tout
simplement enfin corinne lepage vice
présidente du modem semble s'éloigner de
françois bayrou pour se rapprocher de
daniel cohn bendit
il ya des régions ont fait cause commune
ici cheville
pourquoi mais je veux dire dans 10
heures pour le modem si daniel cohn
bendit prédit un échec à françois bayrou
l'intéressé mimi vous quitte mais parce
qu'il ya des gens qui préfèrent non
d'abord pourquoi ils vous employez un
pluriel qui est pas juste il y en a qui
vont à l'ump doute y vont d'un côté de
l'autre ça n'a aucun sens
il ya d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens qui
nous rejoignent
mais pour ceux qui l'ont quitté françois
bayrou a délaissé son parti au profit de
son ambition personnelle
c'est une écurie présidentielle
aujourd'hui uniquement au service de
françois bayrou
quitte à sacrifier tous les élus tous
les adhérents tous les militants il est
dans une stratégie et qui probablement
pas la meilleure pour le mouvement modem
c'est peut-être là boni pour lui c'est
pas forcément la meilleure pour le modem
plus tu sens la permanente là et même
les mauvais sondages font son parti le
lest imperturbable je vous jure que tout
les grands doublé véritable aventure ou
entreprises politiques elles se sont
toujours faites par des gens qui ne
regardaient pas les sondages
car françois bayrou croit dur comme fer
qu une débâcle aux régionales n'entamera
pas sa stature présidentielle